hello I'm Tina village I'm representing
Texas I'm from Colleyville it's in the
dallas-fort worth metro area although
text is big colleyville is small with
only 20 2951 residence here's the city
hall and the public library
behind the sense of beautiful Sports
Complex
and all of this is part of a even larger
complex called the village of follicle
standing in a field of a blue bonnets a
state flower of Texas there are many
fields of bluebonnets along the highways
thanks to a program started in the 1960s
by lady for john
the home station of the puppy the oldest
steam engine still in use in the south
my family and I we always try to help to
plan it and one way that we do that is
to reuse reduce and recycle and one way
that we reuse is that we refill our own
water bottles that's a way that I
conserve energy is that I turn off
lights when I leave the room we also use
canva shopping bags
I walk the library park tennis courts
when the weather permits
my favorite way to acquire knowledge is
to put everything and I mean everything
that I need into a blender but it's best
to put on liquify I mixed all together
putting the funnel and the end of the
funnel in into my ear I hope the nothing
spills
the monarch of what country invented
gross national happiness give up the
answer is Bhutan
you